[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pearl et papeete et sacripant sans les
amis des enfants père lipopette et
sacripant sont des gens charmants sacré
pense jeunes avant mais pas toujours pas
un enfant voit leur message c'est une
chance et ça dépend du jeu
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les amis que selon livarot je
déteste cette saison sauf quand je suis
aux sports d'hiver bien entendu weave
l'idéal ce serait passer l'hiver à la
montagne le printemps à la campagne
l'été au bord de la mer et le top dans
les grands bois un crédit tu sacripant
mais je rêvais haute voix que cette voie
avec cette casserole
je prépare le dîner mesdames il peut
peut-être encore une fois tombé sur un
noyau de cerise
non non non non non les seulement prises
dans les encombrements
elle m'a téléphoné pour que je mette la
soupe sur le feu non seulement quaderni
papeete
ce projet lui dire mais n'y connais rien
en cuisine m'a alors je ne sais pas par
quel bout quoi manger
nous allons aussi mettre à deux mois au
fond ça ne doit pas être très sorcier à
toi malheureux si madame li pape est
tentant des ltte corps est vrai les yeux
si elle qui m étonner en reprend - si
nous ne voulons pas avoir la soupe à la
grimace
nous avons intérêt à trouver une
solution est vite et bien je vous
propose de prendre les livres de cuisine
vous les lirez et au fur à mesure ben je
ferai tout ce que vous direz pas
décidément mon petit sac répond tu es
génial génial
bon alors je vais vite chercher le livre
de recettes de madame lipopette et en
deux tours demain nous allons
confectionner un
dîner digne de lucullus pièce monsieur
lucullus sous l'eau
c'était au temps des romains ce monsieur
avait la cuisine la plus réputée de ce
montant c'était un grand honneur que
d'être invité à sa table
aussi maintenant quand on a fait un très
bon repas on dit j'ai dîné chez lucullus
alors en route pour lui qu'il dise non
non pour l'instant en route pour le palm
à un gang au wiki lui s'attendre à un
petit paul très bien même bon un ogre
oyola au jeu très bien trois buts bon je
vous remercie les petits enfants sages
un rien ne me fait plus plaisir est
maintenant en route pour le grand voyage
s'agrippent aux peut-être nous désigne
un enfant sage attachant dans le val de
marne with the stars un enfant sage une
petite fille dont le prénom commence par
s comme sacripant non non je suis a cru
bon goût de nous re commence par noms
commencent et bien elle s'appelle
stéphanie kadosh 9 avenue de l'europe
94 230 cache en elle à 6 ans elle aime
beaucoup l'école mais elle ne sait pas
encore très bien écrire c'est une chose
qui vient petit à petit quand on
travaille me stéphane y est beaucoup sa
maman quand elle a du travail
c'est très bien être serviable ma petite
stéphanie
je suis ravi de t'inscrire maintenant à
ruffey-sur-seille dans le magnifique
jura
nous accueillons deux enfants une fille
et un garçon est la preuve nous
commençons par g et a comme gilles et
anémone la petite fille ne s'appelle pas
comme ça non ah non non non non il
s'appelle anne et gilles beaudry oui
trente 940 ruffey-sur-seille gilles à
six ans et demi et âme à 4 ans il aime
beaucoup les missions et à l'école ils
font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour bien
travailler
j aime beaucoup aimé dès son grand père
oui à quoi et bien dans tout ce que fait
un grand père n'est ce pas le bricolage
et la remise en état des meubles ont
faim et vous les inscrits fait là n'est
ce pas terrible
il ya un enfant sage à estrées saint
denis dans l'oise
il n'y a pas un enfant sage mais deux
deux garçons ah oui il leur prénom
commence par b et h
comme bruno et henry oui oui c'est bien
ça bruno et henri lecointe gré son sac
60 150 estrées saint denis bruno à 5 ans
et henry ya six ans ils vont à l'école
et ce sont de très bons élèves
c'est très bien ils ont une grande soeur
corinne qu'ils aiment beaucoup car elle
s'occupe d'eux elle leur raconte des
histoires quand il se couche
il ne faut pas oublier rita leurs
chaînes qu'ils vénèrent absolument c'est
leur grande copine bien moi je l'inscris
bras gauche ils sont très gentils vous
avez raison perles hip hop est bon alors
ça qu'on répète que nous ramène dans la
région parisienne à ris orangis
ou c'est une petite fille perd les
papattes wi fi dont le premier commence
percer comme caroline de tous elle
s'appelle christine frais 36 avenue des
hameaux 91 130 ris orangis et la six ans
on la surnomme manou et bien à nous et
une petite fille très douée elle
travaille très bien en classe c'est moi
d'ailleurs elle n'est pas peu fière
d'être la première de sa classe à b
c'est normal bien sûr il sa petite
chienne que note jacques quand elle vous
voie vers l'ip au fait des bons jours on
a des bons jours c'est très gentil
c'est très gentil je l'inscris notre
petite christine où nous sommes encore
dans la région parisienne à moisselles
dans le val d'oise
ce froid se froisser c'est un petit
garçon qui a été sage sobrino mousse
commence par eau comme olivier sessa
olivères antonio lotti 3 rue masséna les
auchan bouffémont 95 570 moisselles
olivier à cinq ans il avait beaucoup de
thèmes quand nous étions au rugby c'est
gentil mon petit olivier c'est gentil
mais tu vois maintenant se finit oui il
est pas toujours très sage mais il
promet de faire des efforts
bien très bien alors je l'inscris il
faut finir nous allons à castres dans le
tarn
oui ce sont deux garçons qui vont clore
le palmarès de ce soir ils apprennent on
commence à s es x comme sébastien et
xavier sendra bien sacripant c'est très
bien il s'appelle en effet sébastien et
xavier livre jacques nouvelle résistants
nouvelle résidence pardon du pont biais
appartement 441 81100 castres sébastien
à 3 ans et xavier à deux ans si bastia
ne va pas à l'école souffre le matin
mais il est très sage et la maison
l'après-midi fait la sieste sans
pleurait moi aussi j'aime faire la
sieste
mais notre petit xavier malade 1
alors on lui fait des piqûres tous les
jours sébastien lembras essai de
l'amuser pour le distraire c'est
vraiment très gentil je les inscrits et
maintenant le grand moment est arrivé
sébastien et xavier les jacks de castres
olivier antonio optique de moisselles
christine frais de ris orangis bruno et
henri lecointe des str saint denis
gillet et anne vaudry de
ruffey-sur-seille stéphanie kadosh des
cachots aller vite trouver votre porte
un préposé des ptt vous y attend pour
vous remettre 1
lieblien de jouer comme ceux ci il est
temps maintenant d'aller manger votre
supplément
bonsoir bonsoir
[Musique]